we getting sweated by the ponies right
now bus buddy oh no what country are
they sweating us right now they're not
this motherfucker right here sweating me
got me in the back of a police car right
now in sweden cuz poor turn it over for
nothing taking us to the station where I
gotta go to pee in the cup for nothing I
ain't did nothing all I did was came to
this country I did a concert
man to Sweden I'll never be back at this
country y'all can thank y'all police
chief and all the people that run you
off all these Department homies face is
doing a report on because profile racial
profile can be snatched me out of my car
call me down right now some of the dog
well I know I glad y'all concerned about
me I made it through they took me down
there made me pee in a cup didn't find
shit no case no nothing but I administer
Farrakhan say it's better to be searched
and I found nothing to not to be
searched at all fuck y'all